[Musique]
bonsoir moussa aksar merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le
président nigérian un mois me do boyrie
qui avait donc fait de la sécurité et la
lutte contre boko haram sa priorité lors
de son élection en 2015 et pourtant ces
attaques et ces événements qui se sont
multipliés peut-on parler d'échec
aujourd'hui absolument peut parler
d'échec de la politique sécuritaire de
mamadou barry depuis qu'il est arrivé au
pouvoir
parce que comme vous le savez il a dit
qu'il va faire de la lutte contre les
groupes djihadistes qui s'est dit dans
cette partie nord du nigeria sa priorité
aujourd'hui après son premier manga et
le second on constate qu'il a hélas
bantam et le mans échoué avec toutes ces
attaques
avec tous ces enlèvements des centaines
d élèves ont été tout à l'heure on l'a
vu dans le reportage on était à l'idée
et même chez lui non loin de chez lui ça
prouve que ça si sa politique
sécuritaire a failli comment vous
l'expliquez vous cet échec une question
de moyens de volonté oui c'est plutôt
une question d' approche parce que comme
vous le savez sur cette partie du
nigeria étaient des lycées il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'infrastructures il n'y a pas
beaucoup de points d'eau il n'y a pas et
des infrastructures sanitaires ils
étaient délaissées comme c'est qu'on a
vu au nord du burkina au nord du mali et
tout c'est toute cette partie elle il
n'y a pas la présence de l'état ce qui
prouve que les groupes jihadistes ont
remplacé l'état et aujourd'hui on
récolte le nigeria récoltes sont en
conséquence du fait qu'il n'a pas placé
et qui n'a pas su mettre des gens dans
cette dans cette partie là pour qu'il
puisse au moins assurer la sécurité de
ces personnes
peut-on imaginer que la présence de
militaires français au niger pousse les
terroristes à se déplacer justement dans
d'autres régions désertiques
non pas du tout comme vous le savez
aujourd'hui sur les gardes
le mode opératoire de shekau décision
malgré leur cession ils ont attaqué une
et à qui profite la frontière nigérienne
ce pour faire une jonction avec certains
groupes qui sévissent le long de la
frontière nigérienne notamment la zone
de maladie et pour qu'il puisse faire
jonction est porté de coups et faire et
est plutôt mené de combat le long de
cette frontière là et avant les fêtes de
fin d'année pour dire qu'ils existent
bel et bien et qu'ils peuvent attaquer
n'importe où et n'importe quoi alors
effectivement la semaine dernière à 60
oui vous bien les i pardonnez moi en ce
qui concerne la fois sur barkan et comme
vous le savez et berkane sookie plus
notamment de la frontière malienne les
trois frontière entre le mali du niger
et du burkina
mais la force marc khanne n'est pas
aussi projetés vers cette frontière
nigériane surtout dans cette partie où
il ya eu c'est aller mal an plus tôt
dans les rues de la tienne si vous
regardez c'est vers le lit du lac tchad
qui a eu beaucoup qui a beaucoup
d'affrontements entre les groupes
terroristes et les forces de défense et
de sécurité des trois pays notamment le
tchad le niger et le nigeria cette fin
d'année particulièrement meurtrière pour
le nigeria la semaine dernière encore 76
permis ont été tués par un groupe
terroriste boko haram
aujourd'hui quelles seraient les
solutions d'urgence pour sortir de cette
spirale violente
les solutions c'est le développement il
faudrait nécessairement que ces étapes
ans à développer saison là qui ont été
délaissées mais aussi et à mener des
actions surtout de renseignement parce
que le renseignement a failli et vous
avez vu il n'ya pas la présence de
l'état il n'ya pas l'école n'y a pas des
infrastructures sanitaires
c'est les groupes djihadistes
aujourd'hui qui font la loi au tour de
tout c'est toute cette bande là toute
cette frontière là qui est très vaste
est ce pour cela qu'il faudrait que ces
états là qu'on semblait le foie rôle et
de liens que l'armement la fois un
militaire ne peut pas apporter des
solutions
désolant il faudrait jouer entre les
deux est la force militaire et les
actions de développement et stabiliser
des zones qui sont déjà acquises ou aux
à ces cas là avant de possibles les
actions militaires alors une dernière
question sur sept les otages ans selon
le gouverneur de la région le
gouvernement serait en pourparlers avec
les terroristes
quelles sont les chances de libérer ces
étudiants est ce qu'on évoque le
paiement d'une rançon par exemple wahid
et les chances sont minces parce que si
vous l'avez suivi tout à l'heure c'est
que et le groupe chico a déjà été
revendiquée c'est cette prise d'otage
mais il ne parle pas des négociations et
c'est serré très difficile pour le
gouvernement nigérian de négocier et la
libération de ces otages la il s'est
blessé au talon
ils vont les angolais dans les actions
de des taux d'autisme notamment proposer
des ombres de bambou dgd merci mme sarr
journaliste d'investigation merci
d'avoir été dans vue de l'extérieur ce
soir